the clark county school district
welcomes back most staff to its
buildings today and for some it's the
first time stepping on campus
since the start of distance education
and that was a year ago
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
live in the newsroom with the latest on
this adjustment kristen
denise yes educators returning as part
of the hybrid transition plan
teachers will use this week to prepare
for students in grades
6 9 and 12 coming back next monday
i did try to visit a high school in
person but ccsd does not want reporters
in buildings especially now since
parents are not even allowed on campuses
for safety reasons but
a few school principals shared photos
with me showing staff
back and the classrooms this is las
vegas high school right here in the east
valley the pictures show
desks set up already and space depart
for social distancing
the principal tells me majority of his
staff came back on campus today
he adds there's a buzz of positivity as
colleagues see each other again
in person despite the circumstances
things are
far from normal but
it's just the fact that we see each
other's cars now in the parking lot
and we cross each other's paths like we
normally would
that just just charges up
our energy at spring valley high school
in the southwest valley staff received
welcome back swag bags as a sign of
support from the administration
one of the gifts included a pin with the
school's mascot wearing a mask
the principal tells me about 98 percent
of his faculty return today
most teachers will work from school
buildings this week
unless they made a request to work
remotely because of health concerns
now coming up at six two teachers talk
with me about their adjustment today
including what it's like to be back
after a year of teaching from home
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now